government has tonight ordered a review
of sexual abuse in schools it follows
claims that teachers may have covered up
offenses
during involving pupils rather in order
to protect
their school's reputation sky's
political correspondent joe
pike joins me now from westminster so
joe how will this review work
well there are two things the government
have announced to say firstly this
review as you say
which ofsted will carry out on behalf of
the government looking into the
situation
as it is now but also looking at whether
there are enough
safeguards and clear processes in place
for schools to act if allegations arise
the second part
of the government announcement is a
helpline run by the nspcc
to provide advice to young people and to
adults too
although those in the department for
education are clear if people believe a
crime has been committed
they should also contact the police this
is what the education
secretary told us earlier this evening
what we wanted to do is take immediate
action that's why
working with the nspcc we have set up a
helpline in order to be able to support
victims
but why we're wanting to go further and
that is why we have asked ofsted
to be able to conduct a full review in
terms of safeguarding
in our schools to protect the best
interests of our children
this is mark i think an acknowledgement
from the government that this issue
is incredibly important serious and also
complex they do need
support to try and work out how to move
forward and the context of course
is the huge number of testimonies from
largely young women and girls over 10
000 testimonies
on the everyone's invited website saying
that these people have been
sexually abused largely they're claiming
by
young men and they believe in many cases
that the response from schools and
educational establishments
has not been good it's not been uh
positive as you say
some believe thinking behind that the
approach is due to the fact that
the school does not want to get into
controversy and doesn't want to put
their male pupils
in a difficult position i think the
government realized that attitudes
and the the work of schools needs to
change
on this and this review and this
helpline is the first step
in trying to achieve that